soir après soir ces jours ci le journal
télévisé apporte son lot de nouvelles en
provenance de syrie des frappes alliées
qui s'intensifie l'ultime bataille
lancée par la coalition internationale
asphyxie les irréductibles mais alors
que l'étau se resserre sur les derniers
combattants de groupes armés état
islamique
une pensée obsède thierry et véronique
on pense aux familles qui ont leurs
enfants vivants et des petits enfants là
bas qu'ils ne savent pas en fait c'est
de la mort en direct s'il voulait les
rois savent de quoi il parle car ils ont
eux même perdu un fils en syrie
quand un jeune brillant sportifs
musiciens le coeur sur la main
converti à l'islam en 2013 embrigader il
est parti faire le djihad
l'année d'après comme qu'un jeune de la
même mosquée un engrenage rapide et
brutale que ses parents n'ont pas pu
arrêter et ce qui est terrible c'est que
donc sa mort nous a été annoncé par un
inconnu sur what that ce qui vous
annoncent à vous demande de vous réjouir
parce que finalement c'est l'état bâti
sur le son des martyrs ces valeureux
c'est un héros syrie et perrot nick ont
senti comme personne le malaise des
autorités face à ces jeunes djihadistes
français sur les 1700 partie en irak et
en syrie
il en reste aujourd'hui moins de 150 les
autres sont morts au combat ou ont été
tués dans des frappes ciblées
comme les frères fabien et jean michel
klein voix de dèche en france éliminée
il y a quelques jours par un drone
américain
information confirmée par les pousses de
jean-michel là on a commencé par drones
et son rang son grand frère
et comme ou socom sa vie il était
présent il était gravement blessé et là
bas on la suit ya deux jours
ces femmes ces enfants et surtout ses
anciens combattants sont aujourd'hui
considérés en combat syrien en principe
ne s'oppose à leur retour en france
emmanuel macron souhaite plutôt qu'ils
soient jugés et emprisonnés
ailleurs en irak par exemple les
français majeurs détenu ou qui seraient
transférés
il relève d'abord des autorités de ce
pays et qu'il revient de décider
souverainement s'ils doivent faire
l'objet de procédures judiciaires sur
place est donnée parmi d'autres mais
selon ce spécialiste du terrorisme
la raison est simple il pose un risque
élevé dans les français ancien ya des
gens qui avaient des fonctions
opérationnelles très élevée quand même
d'endoctrinement acceptant donc ça pose
des problèmes de prosélytisme en prison
et de récidive et c'est donc c'est
réellement une question hypersensible
[Musique]
mais le risque est d'abord et avant tout
politique encore sous le choc des
attentats terroristes
82% des français selon un récent sondage
s'oppose au retour des djihadistes une
réalité impossible à ignorer
à quelques mois des élections
européennes pour autant beaucoup de ces
djihadistes finiront bien un jour ou
l'autre par rentrer et la france tente
le mieux possible de s'y préparer
je pense qu'on ne peut pas se
désintéresser de nos compatriotes y
compris si l'on copie des crimes à
l'étranger l'organisation que dirige
jean marc borello a reçues de l'état
français la responsabilité d'accompagner
les djihadistes en prison et à leur
sortie pour tenter de les réinsérer il
serait irresponsable de les laisser dans
la nature il est beaucoup plus prudent
et responsable de les accueillir et de
les traiter comme ce qu'ils sont c'est à
dire des terroristes dangereux qui
doivent être punis d'abord et après
l'organisation suit actuellement une
cinquantaine d'individus radicalisés un
processus long et complexe qui s'inspire
de la lutte contre la toxicomanie ou
contre l'emprise d'une secte beaucoup
plus difficile que de réhabiliter un
simple détenus de droit commun pour
avoir travailler concrètement sur le
sujet c'est quand même nettement plus
compliqué et il faut être modeste si on
réussit à faire de djihadistes
combattants des musulmans quiétiste ou
salafistes quiétiste judo l'endroit d'où
on part en terme de violence c'est déjà
bien
thierry et véronique le savent mieux que
quiconque qui n'ont pas réussi à ramener
comtadin droit chemin mais il souhaite
quand même que la france rapatrie tous
les djihadistes leurs femmes et leurs
enfants une question selon eux de droits
de l'homme de justice mais aussi de
sécurité vaut mieux avoir cette bombe à
retardement à côté de soi pour pouvoir
éventuellement la désamorcer
plutôt que de l'année c'est là-bas
grandir là bas et puis quand elle
revient ici quand elles explosent alors
à ce moment là bonjour les dégâts
véronique qui avouent penser encore à
quentin tous les jours
plaide quant à elle auprès des autorités
pour un peu d'ouverture de compréhension
de compassion nous on n'a pas cette
chance d'avoir vu que espérer voir
entrer notre enfant d'autres l'ont ne
brisons pas leurs espoirs